Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Isa Alkin.
Ich bin auf dieser Station aus Asistan, ich würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegesprach fürbeln.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstand?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir, das ist mir das Wichtigste.
Okay, wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Irma Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam ustebiren?
Der Vornamen ist I-I-R-M-A Irma.
Und der Familienname ist Müller.
M-U-Umblaut, doppel-L-E-R.
Frau Müller.
Frau Müller, bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden schildern, möchte ich Ihnen ganz schnell ein paar Allgemeinfragen stellen.
Zum Beispiel Ihr Alka, Ihr Gross- und Ihr Gewicht.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Ja, müssen Sie ja haben, die Angaben ist ja schon klar.
Okay, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37.
37.
Und darf ich fragen, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Dürfen Sie, ja.
Ich bin 168 und wiegeln 69 kg.
1 Meter 81 und?
Nee, 1 Meter 68.
68 und?
Wiegeln 69 kg.
69 kg.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Gewusstatung verraten, Frau Müller?
Ja, 13.787.
13.7190?
1907 und 80.
1707 und 80.
Okay, Frau Müller.
Was führt Sie so mehr?
Was kann ich wir so tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Gestern Abend fing es an nach dem Abendessen.
Da dachte ich erst, ich habe vielleicht etwas Verkehrtes gegessen
oder zu schnell gegessen.
Und da war das so um den Bauchnabel rum, tat es ganz tüchtig weh.
Und dann ist es irgendwie im Laufe der Nacht.
Das Abendessen und der Nacht ist es irgendwie gewandert.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen so rechts im Bauch unten.
Und jetzt ist mir auch schlecht.
Und ich musste mich heute Morgen schon einmal heftig übergeben.
Die Schmerzen sind fast,
mehr als normale Magenschmerzen, würde ich sagen.
Die sind wirklich sehr kräftig.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein auffälliges oder verdrückenes Nahrung gegessen?
Nein, wir haben alle das Gleiche gegessen.
Das war alles ganz normales Essen, da war nichts Besonderes.
Okay, okay.
Und könnte Sie bitte dieses Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, so ein bisschen krampfartig ist das.
Und es sticht richtig, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen im Laufe derzeit schlimmer geworden?
Ja, sonst wäre ich nicht gekommen.
Wie starten die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz-Kaliform 1?
Komische Schmerzen bedeuten uns sehr stark.
Wo würden sie denn kommen?
Wo würden sie einordnen?
Das sind schon kräftige Bauchschmerzen.
Zwischen 6 und 7 würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht getraut, was einzunehmen.
Ich habe mich nur ins Bett gelegt, aber im Liegen war es irgendwie auch nicht so richtig gut.
Wenn ich mich so bücke und so ein bisschen so, ja,
oder auch im Bett, wenn ich mich so auf die Seite gelegt habe und so zusammengekommt,
dann war es noch so annäherend auszuhalten, ja.
Okay.
Aber geschlafen habe ich heute Nacht, glaube ich, sehr, sehr wenig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie auch Duphal oder ist Ihnen übel?
Übel ist mir natürlich, ja, ja, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich musste ja auch mich einmal übergeben.
Danach geht es auch nicht besser.
Es ist furchtbar, ja.
Okay.
Es gibt bestimmte Faktöre, die die Schmerzen auslösen.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Das fing ja gestern Abend nach dem Essen an.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es mit einmal ging, das los.
Was dahinter, und das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo aus, Frau Müller?
Ausstrahlen?
Wie gesagt, die waren erst so um den Bauchnabel rum,
jetzt sind sie mir so rechts unten.
Aber ausstrahlen tun sie eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerde oder eine Schmerz?
Gehabt oder ist das zum Ersten?
Jeder hat mal Bauchschmerzen.
Also natürlich, klar.
Aber so in dieser Form, das kenne ich nicht.
Okay, Frau Müller.
Frau Müller, haben Sie viel Bauch oder füllen Sie sich viel?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber jetzt, wo Sie es sagen,
ich fühle mich schon so ein bisschen heiß an.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Müller?
Normalerweise ist es gut, aber heute und gestern,
gestern habe ich ja noch mit Appetit gegessen,
aber dann war es damit vorbei.
Also heute habe ich wahrlich keinen Appetit, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Laufe derzeit ab oder so genommen?
In welcher Zeit?
Im letzten sechs Monaten.
Nein, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich immer stabil,
da bin ich auch ganz froh darüber.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie können wegen der Schmerz nicht gut schlafen.
Früher haben Sie, schlafen Sie gut?
Früher habe ich gut geschlafen, ja, natürlich.
Also normalerweise, das, was ich nach so einem Arbeitstag ist,
man müde und dann kann man gut schlafen, ja.
Okay.
Frau Müller, möchten Sie weitere Details so Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden
hinzufügen, möchten Sie oder?
Nein, ich möchte überhaupt nichts zufügen.
Ich möchte jetzt nur wissen, was wir gegen diese Schmerzen tun können.
Okay, okay.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen bis zum Ende das Aufnahmegesprach aushalten
oder soll ich Ihnen?
Wie lange wird das dauert?
10 Minuten, Frau Müller.
10 Minuten kann man ja noch wegstellen.
Ich habe das schon den ganzen Morgen aber drum besessen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Frau Müller, lassen Sie über Ihre Medizinische vorgeschickt.
Geht das für Erkorkungen von denen ich wissen sollte,
zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder...
Ja, also was bei mir bekannt ist, ich habe eine Schildrüsenunterfunktion
und muss entsprechend also Tyroxin einnehmen, ne?
Deswegen bin ich auch regelmäßig beim Hausarzt.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Das hat man, ich glaube schon so vor 15 Jahren, so Anfang 20 Jahre,
da hat man das festgestellt.
15 Jahre, okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Vorherkorkungen, oder?
Nein, sonst habe ich allerdings, ich kriege vielleicht mal so Husten,
aber sonst, aber so im Rahmen von Erkältungen,
aber sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Sie haben wegen der Erkältung Husten, ja?
Ja, ja, wenn ich Erkältung habe, dann habe ich halt Husten, ne?
Wurden Sie schon einmal Opeljab?
Ja, als Kind sind mir die Mandeln rausgenommen worden.
Wie bitte?
Als Kind sind mir die Mandeln rausgenommen worden.
Mandel.
Und das war alles oder noch andere Operation?
Nein, die Kinder sind normal auf die Welt gekommen,
also da war nichts mit Operationen, also sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Keine Operation.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Erdroxin regelmäßig ein.
Bissen Sie Wichttag oder Bietosierung?
Nein, kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, das passt der Hausarzt ja auch immer so ein bisschen anders,
muss ja ein paar Eingestellt werden.
Also, was ich im Augenblick, ich weiß gar nicht, was da auf dem Tisch liegt, gerade zu Hause,
aber ich habe den natürlich nicht mit die Packung.
Okay, okay.
Und Frau Milga, sind Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Ob mir eine Allergie bekannt ist,
nicht, dass ich wüsste, nein, also eigentlich bisher habe ich immer alles vertragen,
habe auch nie irgendwie schlimmen Ausschlag bekommen oder so,
nein, alle gehen, habe ich nicht.
Okay, okay, Frau Milga.
Um ein unfassendes Bild zu bekommen, hatte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem täglichen Gewohnheiten.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nie geraucht, schön.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig wirklich nicht hin und wieder trinke ich mal in Glas Wein oder wenn es was zu feiern gibt,
in Glas Sekt oder ja, wenn es sehr heiß ist, im Sommer auch mal eine Flasche Bier,
aber wirklich, das ist sehr selten.
Sehr, sehr selten.
Können wir sagen, elegantlich, ja?
Kann man sagen.
Frau Milga, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Es handelt sich um eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie eine Droge oder haben Sie jemals Drogen ausprobiert oder eine Zusatz?
Nein, mit oben habe ich keine Erfahrungen.
Keine Erfahrungen, okay.
Okay, Frau Milga, wie ist Ihr Familienstand, sind Sie verheiratet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Zwei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie von Beruf, Frau Milga?
Ich bin Angestellte bei der Versicherung.
Ich habe eine Teilzeitstelle wegen der Kinder.
Entschuldigung, können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich arbeite nur Teilzeit, damit ich mich um die Familie auch kümmern kann.
Also seid ersehbar, richtig?
Bei einer Versicherung bin ich angestellt, ja.
Okay, und lernen Ihre Alkohol noch, sind Sie gesund?
Meine Eltern leben noch, aber gesund.
Mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt, von dem er sich aber Gott sei Dank gut erholt hat.
Aber die leben beide noch, ja.
Und Mutter?
Für die weiß ich, dass sie gesund sind.
Gesund?
Wie alt ist er als Milchartinfarkt gelitten, der Vater?
Sie meinen, wie alt er war, als er den Herzinfarkt hatte?
Ja.
Da war er Anfang 60, das war ganz überraschend.
Okay, Frau Müller, ich bin mit meinem Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Ja, wie es jetzt weitergeht, was kann man Ihnen jetzt gegen diese Schmerzen machen?
Woher kommen Sie denn?
Ja, Frau Müller, ich werde so erst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und dann natürlich, jetzt soll ich Ihnen eine im Krankenhaus aufnehmen.
Was nochmal, Sie sollen sich eine, was sollen Sie?
Ja, ich so erst werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Das habe ich verstanden. Aber was ist mit dem Krankenhaus aufnehmen?
Ja, um Ihre Diagnose festzustellen, sollen Sie ins Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich muss da bleiben?
Ja, sollen Sie.
Gut, okay.
Da muss ich nur meiner Familie Bescheid sagen.
Da muss ich meinen Mann ja drinnen um die Kinder kümmern.
Ist Ihre menstruärstik das regelmäßig?
Ja, ziemlich, kann man sagen.
Wo ist Ihre Bauchschmerzen? Könnten Sie bitte ganz genau beschreiben?
Rechter Unterbau?
Haben Sie Luftfall oder Verstrufung?
Weder noch, bisher hatte ich gestern den letzten Schulgang.
Haben Sie Bullot im Stuttul bei Mars?
Nein.
Das wären mir aufgefallen, wenn etwas aufgelagert wäre.
Wenn Sie kusten oder bewegen, sind Ihre Schmerzen verstärkt?
Ob die Schmerzen verstärkt sind, würde ich sagen.
Wenn ich zusammengekrimmt sitze, kann ich das Gefühl nicht aushalten.
Oder wenn ich zusammengekrimmt auf der Seite lege.
Wo beginnen Ihre Bauchschmerzen?
Ich habe gesagt, die Bauchschmerzen haben begonnen.
Um den Bauchnabel herum.
Ich dachte erst, ich habe Magenschmerzen.
Danach in der Unterbauer.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, heute schlecht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Eine Frage?
Nehmen Sie Pille?
Nein, ich habe eine Spirale.
Noch eine Frage?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben immer Bauchschmerzen.
Waren Sie beim Bescheiden eine andere Art?
Nehmen Sie eine Diagnose?
Ich habe nur gesagt, jeder hat Bauchschmerzen.
Als der gefragt hat, ob ich solche Bauchschmerzen kenne.
Also jeder hat ja in seinem Leben mal Durchfall gehabt.
Oder Menstruationsschmerzen.
Das kennt jeder eigentlich.
Insofern kenne ich Bauchschmerzen.
Aber solche, wie ich jetzt habe, hatte ich noch nie.
Ist das geklärt?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Einst die Festivals waren rekordmäßig schnell.
Ja.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen Medikamente eingenommen?
Hat er gefragt, habe ich verneint.
Okay.
Was machen Sie?
Können wir dann weiter machen?
Als Absprich?
Ja.
Schönen guten Tag Frau Berastin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen besprechen.
Sie würden gerne mit mir besprechen.
Was ist das denn?
Die Patientin heißt immer Müller.
Sie ist 37 Jahre alt.
1 Meter 68, groß und 69 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Müller stellte sich bei uns.
Frau Müller.
Frau Müller stellte sich bei uns wegen, seit gestern.
Plötzlich aufgetretener bestehender Krampartiker
und bestehender Bauchschmerzen,
ab dem Schmerzen vor.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass die Schmerzen im Präumlikalbereich...
Periumlikal.
Umlikal.
Nicht umlikal. Periumlikal.
Periumlikal Bereich Vagonen hatten.
Dann seien die Schmerzen im rechten Bereich ausgewandert.
Ausgewandert, okay.
Ja.
Die Schmerzen begonnen nach dem Essen.
Die Patientin hat einmal erbrochen.
Und direkt nach dem Essen?
Oder wann?
Heute Morgen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Ja.
Und die Schmerz in der Stadt liegt bei von 6 oder 7
von 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Und...
Als die vegetative Anamnese auffällig in Appetanz und Fieber
füllte die Patientin nicht Fieber.
Aber sie habe nicht Körpertemperatur gemessen.
Sie fühlt sich fieberig, aber sie hat nicht gemessen.
Ja.
Und auch wegen der Schmerzen in Sonja.
Und sie leite an Hypothriose seit 15 Jahren.
Und sie nahm Alatroxin regelmäßig ein.
Sie wurde mit Kinderalte im Kindesalter geführt.
Und sie hatte keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit.
Sie war nicht Raucherin.
Sie trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol,
trocken Konsum, wurde verneidt.
Sie sei verheiratet und sie habe zwei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund.
Sie sei als An-Teilzeit
und als Versicherungarbeiter.
Sie ist Versicherungsarbeiter?
Ja.
Sie ist Mitarbeiterin in einer Versicherung.
Und das heißt Teilzeit.
Teilzeit.
Und die Familienanamnese ist auffällig.
Da hat sie eine Mio-Kartinfarktus mit Zeckzi gelitten.
Und die Mutter ist gesund.
Ja, wegen der erwarten Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdach auf Kolelithiasis aus.
Und aus dem Differenzial diagnostisch kommen akute Apanthesitis.
Nephrolithiasis.
Und inbetrat.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich würde gerne erst eine Körperliha untersuchen dürfen.
Woher achten Sie dabei?
Ja, bei der Bauchabdominal-Untersuchung.
Ich beachte auf die Schmerzlokalisieren.
Ich achte darauf, ob es eine Schmerz gibt.
Wie heißt der Punkt?
Ich kenne den nächsten Moment.
Makbunay.
Ja, wegen der Apanthesitis.
Und ich werde so erst akute Apanthesitis auslesen.
Ich beachte auf die Apanthesatomal-Wahl.
Und die Spannung?
Ja, okay.
Und dann so hier.
Okay, und was machen Sie weiter?
Ja, dann würde ich Blut abnehmen, um wichtige Parameter zu kontrollieren.
Was würden Sie dann bestimmen?
Ja, kleine Blutbild-Syarki, Bicycle.
Und Lebenwerte, Niedermärkte.
Und natürlich, ich möchte eine Troid-Funktion überprüfen.
Ja, okay, weil die Patientin das angegeben hat.
Ja.
Gut, was meinen Sie, wenn die Patientin tatsächlich Koalitiasis hat, wie wäre das vorgehen?
Wie warte?
Machen Sie auch noch eine Bild-Hiebung dann wegen der Geilensteine potenziell?
Ja, ich würde eine Bauchabdomain-Utrasone verordnen.
Als erstes, ja, genau.
Oder selber machen, ne?
Ja.
Dann natürlich Mittag-Utrasone können wir Akute Apandicitis ausschließen.
Okay.
Und ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit der Patientin ist.
Wir werden uns die Patientin nachher angucken.
Hatte ich schon einen Zugang?
Ja, natürlich.
So, ähm, wegende Aufgenommen werde ich eine Zugang legen.
Während der Aufnahme.
Okay, gut, ja.
Und dann schauen wir uns die Patientin nachher zusammen an, wenn sie alle befunden beinahe.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Ja.
Tatsächlich war es der Appendix.
Ja, das ist relativ typisch.
Das ist diese Wanderung vom Bauchlabel nach rechts unten.
Das Ding heißt tatsächlich Murphyzeichen.
Aber ich dachte immer, der Typisch für die Apandicitis wäre der Loslachsschmerz.
Bin ich da auf dem falschen Dampfer?
Oder hat man das früher gemacht und macht das heute nicht mehr?
Ja, die Schmerzlokalisation, die Schmerzkassosung sprechen dafür, dass es eine Apandicitis war.
Nein, ich habe etwas anderes gefragt.
Ich habe gefragt, ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass ein typisches Verfahren,
das ist eine Apandicitis, zu diagnostizieren, das Auslösen von Loslachsschmerz ist.
Der Druck tut nicht weh, aber das Loslassen tut weh.
Ja.
Ist das richtig oder macht man das nicht mehr?
Ja, ist das richtig?
Das heißt...
Müssen die Kollegen vielleicht irgendwie mal, muss man jemanden Stellung nehmen?
Reborn.
Loser Schmerzen, genau.
Loser Schmerzen.
Ja, Loser Schmerzen.
Das heißt, macht Bündnis-Seichen.
Ach, das ist dieses Besagte.
Okay.
Ja, ich wusste nicht, wie das heißt.
Ich kenne das nur eben unter der Bezeichnung Loser Schmerzen.
Okay, gut, danke schön.
Ja.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist,
wir haben wieder schön den Unterschied an einem Lese sprachlich einwandfrei
oder sagen wir mit weniger Einschränkungen in der Formulierung im Arztarztgespräch.
Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Immer noch haben wir das Problem mit ihrer Aussprache,
dass die DEs alle zu AS machen.
Und dadurch ist es schwer, sie zu verstehen.
Und so, was habe ich denn noch gehabt?
Genau, der Vater hat mit 60 an einem Herzinfarkt gelitten.
Das ist ja eigentlich so ein...
Er hat einen Herzinfarkt erlitten, weil da der ganze Kram hinterherkommt,
aber hat ihn eben überstanden.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so eine Information.
Ja, dann auch im Blick.
Ich hatte mir noch irgendwas aufgeschrieben.
Ja, das ist so ein Problem.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist,
Sie haben praktisch nicht daran gedacht,
dass das eine junge Frau ist, fraglich,
eine gynecologischen Diabnose.
Die könnte ja auch eine extra Utteringravidität haben
oder endometriose, aber das Gegenspricht natürlich,
dass sie die Schmerzen nicht immer hat.
Und...
Aber danach hatten sie halt gar nicht gefragt.
Im Status haben sie nicht gefragt.
Und letzte Mahlzeit ist natürlich,
wenn man die Appendizitis irgendwo so im Kopf hat,
wäre das natürlich noch annähernd interessant,
wann die Patientin zuletzt was gegessen hat,
ob man die in Zweifelsfallen zeitnah operieren kann.
Ja, das sind so meine Punkte.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das signalisiert,
wenn ich sie nicht gut verstehen konnte.
Und wenn es sprachlich, also zu kompliziert war,
dass man das nicht nachvollziehen konnte,
und das ist das, was sie jetzt meinen.
Aber das sind die altbekannten Sachen.
Also da erzähle ich Ihnen jetzt nichts Neues.
Das haben wir bei jedem Gespräch bisher gehabt,
dass wir eben diese Verständigungsprobleme haben.
Und dass Sie auch unter Umständen meine Frage nicht richtig verstanden haben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was wir dagegen tun können.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich super schnell spreche.
Insofern meine ich müsste von Ihrer Seite verständnis möglich sein.
Und bei Ihnen wiederum dieses Verschlucken von Silben
oder Ziehen von Silben,
das werden Sie sich nicht so schnell abgewöhnen können.
Sondern, dass es eben Ihre Art zu sprechen.
Und damit wird es aber schwer für den Ausmischtein,
Sie gut zu verstehen in der anderen Sprache.
Ja, so viel als Rückmeldung von mir.
Wollte noch irgendjemand etwas dazu sagen?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Dann haben wir es geschafft für heute.
Wir sehen uns dann.